[Music]
so
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
thank you
so
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to
tonight's table service and
here we are continuing another week
of virtual services it feels like this
is dragging on forever
and um we're so eager for the day where
we get to meet in person
but we want to welcome you to this space
um
virtual though it may be um our hearts
are with you
and um we are still so grateful for the
opportunity to connect
and to see you guys my name is maggie
tilford and i'm part of the leadership
team at the table
and um i just you know
last week we didn't get to do this
virtual
live feed because we got to see a lot of
you in person at our
one year anniversary or birthday i don't
know what to write
i don't know exactly what the right
thing is to call that but
um we did a drive through service and we
just want to say
thank you to all of you who took time to
come
that just really meant the world and
um it i just my i left with
such a full heart and for those of you
who weren't able to make it for whatever
rhyme or reason
we just want you to know that you were
thought of you were missed
we love you and we look forward to the
night next time we get to see you in
person
um speaking of meeting in person if
you have not already found
a group um at the table to meet with
we have meetup groups who meet virtually
we have meetup groups who meet live
and we want to give you every
opportunity to stay connected
and in relationship with other people
during this pandemic
and we feel that that is so valuable so
if that is something that you're
interested or needing
um sarah johns is backstage tonight and
helping us out thank you sarah
and she'll be posting a link in the
comments so
be sure to click on that link and find
out about some of the groups that we
have to offer
and where they meet when they meet how
they meet and find one that works for
you
um we feel like those connections are
integral
um to our lives and um
we want to continue to welcome you and
invite you into those
so um with that being said tonight's
service
this is brett's last message on
um the series we've been in called
dealing with difficult
texts and just talking through scripture
and some of the things there
that can trip us up or can really seem
problematic or cause us to question
you know does this line up or how do we
you know make sense of some of the
things that are in scripture and
i hope that this i hope that this series
has been
serving you and that you feel the
permission
and the invitation to join us in talking
openly
and honestly about some of those things
it's not something we want to
sweep under under the rug or try to
pretend that they're not there or cover
them up but we want to open
up conversation that is part of who we
are at the table that's part of our
values
we really want to push towards honesty
and authenticity
um and so anyways we hope that you've
been enjoying it
and um that it's been helpful for you
and that you enjoyed this last
series um or the last message in the
series tonight
um ryan baybron is gonna kick
off our worship excuse me our worship
time tonight
with a song that um we asked him to
record for
us and thank you ryan for doing that um
this is a song by jordan cearcy called
introducing no i think it's actually
called explaining jesus
and um i always want to call it
introducing jesus but
um and um we just
wanted to use it as sort of a um
way of opening the doorway to everyone
who's um
joining us tonight and kind of just
setting the table
um for anyone and everyone who's
interested
and we hope you feel welcome we hope you
feel wanted
we hope you feel loved here and um
as we move into this time i just want to
say a prayer to kind of transition us
into that and i thought i would share a
quote
this was such a crazy week you guys for
all of us in america it's been such a
crazy weekend as the election and the
counting and the voting just kind of
rolled on and on and on it could feel so
much like an emotional roller coaster
and i kept trying to like tell myself
maggie
when you feel anxious when you feel
worried turn it into prayer
turn it into prayer don't let it eat you
alive
and i heard this quote from a leader who
i follow on instagram her name is joe
saxton
and she has such good stuff to say that
i just wanted to share it with those of
you who
may be interested but she said i wrote
it in my journal
um prayer is the precursor to action
it is never a goodbye always a hello
that was from joe saxton i thought oh my
goodness
that was such a great way for me to
frame all my emotions and
and my posture um this week
and um so as we move into this service i
just want to pray
um and help us kind of posture ourselves
for whatever god has for us
and as we pray i just invite you to open
your heart up with me
and let it be a hello let it be a hello
to whatever god has for us wherever he's
moving us
wherever he's challenging us or pulling
us forward drawing us forward
and not a goodbye not a i don't want to
think about this let's just pray
or you know let's escape reality but
always a hello
and and sort of our yes to god's
invitation to moving
into embracing this life more and more
every day
so god i do that right now
um even in my own heart in my own mind
i just want to re-center
and come back to that place of surrender
where i just open up my heart and mind
and i pray that as a community you would
allow all of us
to do the same god let this be our
moment to say hello
our moment to join you
in this journey
and to remember that you are the author
and perfecter of our faith so
this storyline that we're living god
sometimes
it does feel out of our control it feels
um like you know life is happening to
us and um
god rather than sitting back and
um rather than any
any posture that would be um
putting ourselves in the passenger seat
god i want us to
show up fully right now to whatever you
have
and um instead to see it
just like we're going on a long walk
with you
and and we want to show up and we want
to be hand in hand
and we want to follow you wherever
you're taking us
so we pray for all that you're doing in
and among us
and open ourselves up to it
and it's in your name that i pray amen
if you're gay and over 85
then you thought for your whole life
that when god
made you he just messed up
and if you've been raised the southern
belt
born and bred for show-and-tell but you
lie down
feeling never good enough
i'm so sorry for how it's been
we're broken artists
with broken pens
we paint our pride
and we call the truth
i'm sorry no one explained jesus to you
[Music]
if you've heard a knock in your front
door
but all that you found on the porch was
a pastor that just
wanted to be right
and if you really wanna pray to him
but you're never sure he's listening
cause who could forgive what you did
that night i'm so
sorry for what you've heard
i'm a broken poets
with silly words
we paint agendas
and we call it truth
i'm sorry no one explained jesus to you
[Music]
can't you feel him in the room
all he wants is you
but i'm so sorry
for all the wrongs
broken singers with
stupid we songs
our fear we call the truth
i'm sorry no one explained jesus
to you i'm sorry no one
explained jesus to you
i'm sorry no one explained to jesus
to you
[Music]
uh
thank you ryan
[Music]
known and loved by
i'm wonderful
you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good you make
all things work together
for your glory
and for your name
there's a healing light
just beyond the clouds though i've
walked
[Music]
you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good you make all things
work together
for your glory
[Music]
lord remind me i'm
no failure
[Music]
for my future
and for my good you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name you're not
finished with me you're not finished
with me
you're not finished with me
[Music]
and
come all proud come on
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
come from the shadows
[Music]
this room at the table
we sent you a seat
[Music]
every race every
to the table full of grace
to the table come and stay
come to the table
come eat and drink
[Music]
come let down your guard
you're never a stranger
just come as you are
[Music]
accepted
come now come
come
[Music]
come loved
come accepted
come now come
[Music]
prepared
we're ready to feast
[Music]
the party is waiting
there's more still a fear
is ready go fill
every seat
go live
as a kingdom of priests
[Music]
loves
come
[Music]
yeah father god thank you for this time
together
i pray that your spirit would fill us
lord
and that our hearts and our minds our
ears will be open to you lord
[Music]
and i pray you use brett through this
message god help him to speak your heart
[Music]
and father that we would hear and
receive what you have for us lord
[Music]
father we love you
and it's in jesus name we pray amen
[Music]
amen good evening everyone
grace and peace uh i wanted to name
just how incredibly grateful i am to all
of the artists at the table
um who had just such a richness
and really a depth to our
just our worship experience i saw in the
comments um
roy parker had mentioned that and just
thanking the worship team
and um so i just wanted to second that
i'm so grateful tonight it was ryan and
gary
um you know normally it's um mindy is
our worship leader and then her just
entire team i won't go through everyone
because
inevitably i'll forget someone um but
i'm just i'm really grateful for
for those folks so uh yeah all right
second
i also want to just just name how um
just
it was just so good like maggie
mentioned just to see your faces many of
your faces
last week at our our drive-thru
communion one-year anniversary
in time that's a very long title um but
it was just it was great just to have
this moment you know this small moment
of reconnection
in the midst of kind of a you know a
desert of relational isolation
um that so many of us have been
experiencing so that was really
um it was just beautiful so thank you
for those who
who made it out that meant so much so
tonight is the sixth and
the the final part of our series um
titled scripture dealing with difficult
texts
and throughout the series uh we have
been looking at various passages and
topics
um like maggie mentioned often that kind
of make us squirm
you know the i mean from passages that
seem quite anti-gay
to uh verses that portray god as quite
violent
um we've been just discussing all the
undiscussable things
and while i didn't realize it quite when
we began this series um in so many ways
this really has been a chance
for us to sort of um just talk about
some of the theology some of kind of the
the approach to christian faith that
makes the table
a bit unique um and not so much unique
historically i think we're still in the
tradition like the long tradition of the
church um but
kind of in our more you know
conservative bible
bible belt largely evangelical christian
context
um you know we have a few things that
are a little bit a little bit quirky a
little bit different in our theology
and so this series has been um you know
a chance for us to kind of express some
of that which is i think been really
helpful so
you know with that in mind if you missed
previous messages um in this series i
encourage you to go back
and give it a listen um give those
messages listen just they've just proven
quite important to who we are as a
community i think they'll give you some
clarity
so all right let's get into our message
for tonight
it is titled us for them
us for them and our primary texts are
going to be
john chapter 14 verses one through six
and then acts chapter four verses eight
through twelve uh we'll start with this
passage from
john so this is jesus speaking
and he says this do not let your hearts
be troubled
you believe in god believe also
in me my father's house has many rooms
if that were not so would i have told
you that i'm going there to prepare a
place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come back and take you to be
with me that you also may be where i am
you know the way to the place where i am
going
thomas said to him lord uh we we don't
know where you are going so how can we
know the way
jesus answered i am the way
in the truth and the life no one comes
to the father
except through me
all right now acts chapter 4 beginning
in verse 8.
then peter filled with the holy spirit
said to them
rulers and elders of the people if we
are being called to account today for an
act of kindness shown to a man who was
lame
and are being asked how he was healed
well then know this
you and all the people of israel it is
by the name of jesus christ of
nazareth whom you crucified
peter he's a real crowd pleaser whom you
crucified
but whom god raised from the dead that
this man
stands before you healed
jesus is the stone you builders rejected
which has become the cornerstone
salvation is
found in no one else for there is no
other name
under heaven to which mankind by which
we are given to mankind by which we must
be
saved all right so as you can hear
uh these passages you know they they
don't seem to be naming
that jesus is one
revelation of god among others instead
as i've really been saying throughout
this series they're naming that jesus is
the highest the
the most true the most beautiful and
powerful revelation of god
that we have so here's the question that
i've been
wrestling with how can i confess
that jesus is lord and yet
still be for people of
other religious traditions
and the reason this has been on my mind
is because a few years ago i came across
a
quote that that in many ways cut me kind
of to the quick it was by the
indian uh hindu historian and
philosopher
named ananda kumara swami and if you
know anything about indian history you
know
the british controlled india as a colony
for like nearly 200 years
and britain was largely christian so of
course christian missionaries
you know flooded in to convert the
heathen in india but then india is
largely hindu and muslim
so there was there was just a lot of you
know pushback and religious
tension is kind of putting it mildly so
so it's
it's really in the midst of that context
uh
that basically whenever kumara swami was
in dialogue with a christian leader or
like a christian pastor or
or writer or something he would often
say some version of this quote this is
the quote i came across
he said even if you are not on our side
we are on yours and that is something
that
all your zeal cannot take away from us
isn't that beautiful even if you are not
on our side
we are on yours what's he saying
well in effect he's saying look even if
you
christians do not support us
we support you even if you want to fight
us
we do not want to fight you even if
you won't love us we love you
in another version of this line he
doesn't use the language of side but
instead he simply says
even if you are not for us we
are for you i think the reason this cut
me to the quick
was because it's so kind and generous
i mean it would almost be easier to
dismiss if kumar saw me if he just said
oh so you think you're right you
christians come in here trying to
convert us you think you're right well
you're not
you're not right we're right and then
you know we could kind of fight and feel
real good about ourselves
but instead his posture it seems
to be so dare i say it christ-like
i mean it sounds so much like the jesus
who said love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you
even if you
are not on our side we are on
yours now this brings up the question of
of you know why kumar swami would put it
quite that way why would he feel like
christians are not
for him or for people of differing
religious traditions
why would he feel that we are in some
sense against
them now obviously that's a big question
with a long history
some of which are already named above at
least in his specific
you know context i mean i mean it gets
into all sorts of complicated questions
like
what does it mean to um you know engage
like to be a missionary to engage a
different culture
um and people and religion with the good
news of jesus i mean is it okay to like
proselytize and try to convert
others uh and i mean if jesus is lord
wouldn't you want to invite others to
worship the lord but in is that kind of
forcing your beliefs on that you know it
very quickly
um this gets quite complex a little
messy
um so rather than getting into all of
those questions right now
um let me just start by naming
that i think lurking in the background
of a lot
of those questions is is
the the question of hell and who goes
there i do think our doctrine of hell
has quite a bit to do with it
uh this of course goes right back to my
message two weeks ago
many of you will recall that's that's
kind of what we unpacked um
and and kind of what i named was that a
version of the gospel
that says something like this you know
through the cross of jesus
a very small minority of human beings
who have ever lived i.e the christians
will be united with god forever while
the vast majority of people who did not
believe
or perhaps never even heard will be
tortured for all eternity
by a loving god you can see how that
would
that put a bit of a damper on our
relationship with people of other
religious traditions uh and i think
that's true for a number of reasons i
mean a
it can it can kind of make us feel quite
superior
you know which that doesn't lend itself
to good relationships and b
it can it can also just make us feel
plain anxious
kind of giving us that sense of uh you
know like oh i'm just i'm worried for
you i i
i kind of need you to change i need you
to change for your own good i don't want
you to burn in hell forever
and and so you can see how that also
doesn't lend itself to
um you know maybe the healthiest of of
relationships so
so i do think you know changing how we
view hell in judgment
knowing that christ died for all and
that in the end his love will find
us heal us restore us
and that it's not about you know simply
saying the magic word jesus but but
about orienting ourselves
towards love i do think that that starts
to change things for us as we relate to
people of
other faiths or of no faith at all um
because you know suddenly it's not like
we are the insiders
you know we are god's favorites the only
ones going to the good place
and they are the outsiders uh no no god
loves everyone
god died for everyone god rose again for
everyone and god will
in the end find a way to save everyone i
believe that
uh and and i do think that that helps
helps us
kind of relate to people um because
we're no longer just
anxious for them in the sense of oh i
need you to believe just like me or else
you're going to be tortured forever
uh so so in other words when when we no
longer understand hell as eternal
conscious torment
um we've removed a very large elephant
from the room so to speak
so that's all good and helpful but
it does still leave the question
how do i as a christian think about and
relate
to other religious traditions and the
people that adhere to them because you
see when
when i began to um even if you go back
and listen to my message
or if you were here two weeks ago and
you listened to it like the way i
unpacked
this kind of new understanding of hell
what i named was that
god in christ is drawing
all people to himself right so it's very
christian
um and it's very inclusive right i mean
i'm not i'm not leaving out people
um but i am saying that jesus
is doing the saving right which
presumably
means that um i mean however you want to
frame it that other religious figures or
gods or whatever are not doing the
saving or at the very least not to the
to the same degree and um
and thus you know i'm saying that that
as a christian
um that i mean that would just kind of
presume that that somehow
you know focusing on christ or centering
on christ
is um you know kind of gets you closer
to ultimate truth than other
traditions and belief systems that may
sound
really i don't know rude or
yeah i don't know how that strikes
people but i think that's kind of
embedded in
christian faith i mean to say you know
jesus is lord um
you know kind of means he's the lord so
it's it's like i said it's kind of
complicated like how does this
what does this mean for how i relate to
people um so so in other words
like perhaps then we're just sort of
stuck
like either jesus is lord
and all the things we just read in acts
you know 4 8 through 12 and john 14 like
all those things are true
so jesus is lord and we agree with that
and so we're automatically tempted by
this sort of
arrogance and the worst sort of
christian triumphalism
so either that or or if we let go of
that
uh well then we are arrogant anymore uh
but we've also sort of lost our
christian identity
and and really any teeth in the call to
discipleship right this powerful call
to align ourselves with the the god
revealed in jesus the god
who is love and and honestly i think
that's that's a beautiful
um call and that's not something to just
let go of uh but
there you have it right that's the
that's the dilemma
um to put it in slightly different words
do we still boldly proclaim jesus's
lord and then let that kind of trip us
up with a temptation
toward arrogance or do we let go of the
idea that jesus is lord and that through
him all creation will be saved
but then we've lost our christian
identity so so this kind of begs the
question all right
is there a way beyond this um
beyond this impasse so to speak so as
i've been reflecting on this last few
weeks where my mind just kept going
was back to our need for what i'll call
a
better more robust that's such a
brett word robust doctrine of the holy
spirit
also a brett word doctrine perhaps that
word sounds kind of stodgy
um it just means you know essential
christian teaching
doctrine of the spirit and i think that
we often get the idea
that god is somehow limited to
us and our people christian people
that god is somehow limited even to the
church
and that if you want to encounter god or
reach out for god or meet god in any way
then you must
call yourself a christian or go to a
church or take communion or read the
bible
and until that happens well sorry you
may think you're experiencing god
but really it's probably just the demons
fooling you
uh and of course i no i just i don't
think that's
true i mean honestly like just think of
your own life
how many of us look back on our lives
long before we were ever christians
and and we can unmistakably see
that the holy spirit right the spirit of
god was
calling us and drawing us
towards god's self can you kind of do
you have those experiences like as you
look back
and how many of us have like perhaps
you've maybe studied another religion
um or just you know you've interacted
with one a bit
and you found in its teachings um
marvelous
good and just beautiful things
um like how many of us have met someone
from a very different uh faith and we
get the hey sweetie i know what happened
to the sink
you know what happened to the sink yeah
you think oh
good that's such good news um so i'm
talking to some friends can i can i
can i finish this up if someone put too
much
oh they put you up that does it every
time huh someone put too much in the
sink
okay sweet
love you lots
i love oh she's blowing me kisses
oh thank you um i love
church online full of surprises all
right so um
how many of us have met someone
from even a different faith right so now
i'm not talking about studying like
reading
their holy book or something but i'm
talking about just a personal
relationship
where you you know someone of a
different faith and
and you get the sense that they
might be a better christian so to speak
than you are
like like they're already better in fact
you might even say that the fruit of the
spirit right you might ask what do you
mean by better i mean you know the fruit
of the spirit
love joy peace patience kindness
goodness and so on like it's all there
it's all happening in them i mean not
that they're you know perfect
but you just get the sense that that
that somehow
um through their life their experiences
their relationships and
even their religious tradition like
they're they're meeting
god in some very real way
all right so what am i driving at this
is what i'm trying to name that
god through the presence of the holy
spirit
is accessible and available
to all people that's what i'm naming
god the presence of the holy spirit is
accessible and available
to all people you say who are all people
well all people
everyone to buddhist people and hindu
people and muslim people and
non-religious people
and on and on it goes god is present and
available
to all people now perhaps this is making
you nervous you're like is this in the
bible so let's look at this text this is
acts chapter 17.
this is the apostle paul preaching to a
non-christian audience
in acts 17 verses 24-28
paul said this the god who made the
world
and everything in it is the lord of
heaven and earth and he does not live
in temples built by human hands
can you see how he's already kind of
setting the stage for this this kind of
idea of god's spirit you know being
in and through all things and being
present to people he does not live in
temples built by human hands and he is
not
served by human hands as if he needed
anything rather he himself gives
everyone life
and breath and everything
else what's that saying i mean your very
breath is is a gift of god
it's it's it's through the presence of
god
right it's this miracle can you hear
kind of the doctrine of the spirit there
god's presence and availability to
everyone
verse 26 from one man he made all the
nations
that they should inhabit the whole earth
and he marked out their appointed times
in history
in the boundaries of their lands god
did this so that they would seek him
and perhaps reach out for him
and find him
though he is not far from any one of us
isn't that beautiful for he is not far
from any one of us
for in him we live and
move and have our being
like literally our existence
is sustained by god as some of your own
poets have said
we are his offspring
in other words even non-christian people
can be in touch with god
can begin to discern what goodness is
can discern
that we are all as he said offspring
we're all children
of god and thus begin to live in a way
that delights god
and of poor of course um paul's a
christian right so he goes on from there
to to name to articulate that that what
was sort of
seen vaguely or intuited
what was what was somewhat hidden before
is now
made more clear in jesus christ
um but notice paul isn't saying
oh you people don't know anything oh
you've never had any connection to god
at all
how would you know right and wrong how
could you claim to know god in any way
you've all been doing nothing but
worshiping demons no
no instead he assumes a certain level of
revelation
he assumes that that actually people do
know god
and then he goes on to proclaim what he
believes is the highest the most
profound
revelation of god in jesus christ so
so what does this kind of change for us
um well i want to get at that
from a quote i love this quote this is
from a theologian named nicholas healey
where he's reflecting on on this idea
that through the holy spirit god is
present to
all people and that his um his grace and
love
meet them there even if you know maybe
they never even heard the name jesus or
something
uh this is what healey says the
non-church world
is thus not only the place in which the
church is to witness to its lord right
that would be jesus
it is also the place from which the
church
may learn about its lord
and about true discipleship
keywords there may learn
about the lord i love that i i really
think this starts to change our mindset
um because suddenly see when i interact
with someone
who is not a christian on the one hand i
feel like
i can bring my full self right and my
full beliefs
and all my convictions about who jesus
is um i don't have to be
mousy about that i don't have to pretend
like oh
i really don't think jesus is all that
great because you know i wouldn't want
to offend you
and i know how fragile you are no no i
can bring my full self and guess what
so can they right they can bring their
full selves
all their convictions and beliefs but
here's the key
dialogue doesn't have to break down
into a monologue why
just because i believe jesus is lord
does not mean
i have nothing to learn from them
in fact they may teach me something
about the god who
is love they may teach me something
about what
faithfulness to god into christ
looks like this is this is not just
theory for me this is something that's
been very true in my own
life uh for years uh i
could not really pray in any consistent
way
i was sort of that guy who for three
days
would be up at six a.m to pray like i
would redouble my efforts i was like i'm
gonna do it
uh and then you know i wouldn't pray
again for like two weeks
and then back for a day and then off for
a month and i was just i was bad at
prayer
i mean i would try right i would sit
down to pray but my mind would wander
i would have this expectation of
experiencing god and then i'd be
discouraged when nothing happened
and i just i didn't like it i didn't
like praying i just didn't get it
and i didn't get i just didn't
understand like how this was supposed to
kind of happen quite what i was supposed
to feel and i felt bad like i felt
guilty
christians should pray jesus talked
about that um
and yet today i pray nearly every day
really like to pray uh you know who
taught me to pray
zen buddhists is that weird
it was busy through their books and
their writings that i started to get it
i learned the value of sitting my butt
down
and putting away the distractions in
all the ways the myriad of ways
that i run from myself and from god
and it was actually through silence and
meditation
that i then learned
oh now i get it from this place
from this quiet place now
now i can speak words to god that
resonate i
learned that prayer is primarily
presence
and it was actually through zen teachers
as they talked about
christian contemplatives like thomas
merton and meister eckhart and julian of
norwich
that i learned about the whole christian
kind of mystical contemplative tradition
um that also values silence like in
other words it took a different
religious tradition
to help me learn about my own tradition
like they were all talking about
christians and i'm like
who are these people i never heard these
people so i took the buddhists they'd
teach me about christianity
uh and then once i learned then all of a
sudden i'm like off and running
and i'm honestly i'm a better christian
today
i am more faithful to christ
because of what they taught me uh now
now i mean you know everything you find
and every philosophy and religious
tradition is all just sunshine and
rainbows
like of course not right evil is present
in in every culture
and every tradition um but heck even the
church isn't exempt from that like if
you know any church history
we've had um some dirt days so
so right we have to be wise we have to
discern
but that should not stop us from
approaching
people and traditions very different
than our own
in in a spirit of kindness
and thoughtfulness and humility
because sometimes it's from them that we
will learn about our lord
and about christian discipleship you see
it's not
us verse them is it
it's us for them so
to come back to our original question uh
how can i be christian
and yet also be for people of other
religious traditions okay i want to sum
this up
how can i desire to witness to others
about the beauty of christ
and yet not get super weird and feel the
need to like force them to change
um and i actually think it's not like
all that complicated it's
it's not easy but it's simple um when i
interact
i am there both to witness to the god
who is love
and to learn about the god who is
love that means it's give and take and
now we have the basis for dialogue
and relationship and when you couple
that kind of insight with my message two
weeks ago
um right about hell i think you can see
how as the christian writer brian
mclaren says um
that too often when we quote the verse
about jesus being the way that's in the
passage i read
above in john 14 at the very end it
sounds
like we're often saying he's in the way
right jesus is the way
um as though he's in the way as if
mclaren says as if people are trying to
come to god
but jesus is blocking the path he's
saying like
oh no you don't you have to get by me
first
uh in other words jesus isn't blocking
the way
he is opening up a way for
all people and everyone to connect with
god
and i think those two insights together
can become a
very beautiful path for us to be both
christian and yet emotionally and
relationally for
people very different than ourselves it
truly is
us for them so before i pray let me
point in the direction of just a few
resources if you'd like to learn more
about these things the first is a video
um this is a talk by rowan williams
called the finality of christ in a
pluralistic society you can find it on
youtube
if you search any of those words in the
name rowan williams it will come up
and then um second is a book a new kind
of christian
by brian mclaren all right let me go
ahead and pray for us
jesus we love you
we're so grateful for the way that
you've opened up
for us and all people and
um and we also got ask forgiveness
for for how we've let that become the
source of pride we've
let that kind of divide us and
and distance us from people and
um even caused us or it's sort of
tempted us to slip into this arrogant
mode
where we're the people with all the
answers
and none of the questions and god we
repent for that
and we ask
that you would renew us that you would
give us a new way
of relating to folks and um that it
would be beautiful
and life-giving where we can both
name who you are and what you've done in
our lives
and yet also listen and learn and be
ready to hear
what your holy spirit has taught them
god so lead us
all into truth into beauty in the
goodness lead us all in the way of jesus
it's in the life-changing name of christ
that i pray amen
[Music]
[Applause]
when it's us
[Music]
is love there's no need to shed more
blood
look upon the cross
[Music]
his judgment
there is no more guilt
there is no more shame
our darkest sin
our deepest pain
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
we will not fight their wars
we will not fall in love
cause if it's us for them it's us
for them
[Music]
it's us for them
[Applause]
[Music]
me
and his judgment is
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well thank you guys so much
for joining us
and um it was fun watching all the
comments and conversation happening
tonight
as the message unfolded and children
entered and exited and all the fun so
thank you thank you thank you i hope you
enjoyed that last song
and mindy has been wanting to share that
for a long time now
and has been talking about that song
forever um
so she thought it'd be a great week to
include that
and kind of give us the lyrics to
reflect on that message
um we want to make sure that we name
that if there is something that you're
going through or
in your life that's heavy on your heart
and you want
prayer or you need that we want to make
sure
to make ourselves available to you in
whatever way we can so
please kick us a message on facebook
or you can go on our website and fill
out the online form there
but please know that we're available and
that we want to be there for you
in a tangible way as you walk through
whatever might be going on in your life
right now
we're here with you and you're not alone
and
um that i think can be one of the
trickiest parts of this pandemic is just
the feeling of being alone and that's
not true and we want to push that
push back on that and let you know that
we're here so
um yes please
um go and fill those out if if that's
something that you're needing or
interested
in and if this community if you're
resonating with the values
and the vision that we have and you're
able to give financially
that is a huge gift for us at this time
and we just want to invite you to do
that and just put out a reminder i think
sarah will be posting the link as well
but our website is thetabletx.com
and you can um give there um
and finally we just want to send you out
with a blessing
may you go with the peace of christ
and may you find him near to you this
week
and may you bring that same peace
and love to the world around you go with
god
we'll see you soon bye friends
you